[Music]
we are we're really honored to have Anna
Lee back for her second time speaking
for us for her new book she wrote a
time-travel book just for no yeah with
this is a it's it's it's a great book
and it's we're gonna have a great
discussion for you tonight Anna Lee
Nuits is a SAN francisco-based writer of
both science fiction and nonfiction and
they are the authors of the latest book
future another timeline as well as the
lambda literary award-winning novel
autonomous as a science journalist you
can find Anneliese writing in New York
Times The New Scientist and the popular
science and Ars Technica amongst many
others and you may also be familiar with
Anneliese work from the actually a Hugo
award-winning podcast I didn't I
this is me I didn't realize that Hugo
was recognizing podcast now about time
Hugo
so our Hugo winner but but our opinions
are correct which is fantastic and with
Charlie Jane Anders another great local
author so tonight to to explain to us
how it is we're in the wrong time line
please join me give you a big round of
applause to our speaker Anna Lee newest
it's great to be back and talk to you
guys about another thing that I made up
about science so I promise one day I'll
be back here to talk about actual
science so what I want to do today is
talk a little bit about the novel that
I've just written um let's see if I can
make this ha ha so I just wrote this
novel which is about time travel just
for the long now and I wanted to talk a
little bit about the process of writing
it and how I did the world-building for
it because building an alternate
timeline and building a time machine
we're actually a kind of a long
interesting process but then what I want
to really get into is the question of
why we keep returning to stories about
time travel and what is it what are the
kinds of human stories that we can tell
when we talk about time travel what are
some of the themes that are brought up
again and again and maybe why right now
we all have this feeling that maybe
we're in the wrong time line and maybe
time travelers have something to do with
that weird moment when the Cubs won and
2017 its 2016 sorry see alternate
timeline so my novel is about time
travel as I said but it's also really
about two people and I'll be reading to
you a little bit from it and so you can
meet them but one of them is a time
traveler her name is Tess it's set in a
world where time travel is mundane so
everyone knows about time travel there's
no secret time machine everyone has been
doing time travel for a very long time
so Tess works as a scientist and her job
is partly to use this machine to go back
in time and she is trying to change the
past which is not considered to be a
very it's not really considered to be
something that academics should do it's
a little bit outside the polite norms of
academia and she's going back to the
19th century
and she discovers very early in the
novel that she's actually in a war
against another group that's also trying
to change history and it's a group of
men who have been deleting women's
reproductive rights from the time line
they've been figuring out crafty ways to
make that happen so Tess lives in a
world where abortion is not legal in the
United States and so Tess keeps crossing
paths with the other main character
named Beth Beth is not a time traveler
in fact she's very annoyed that she has
to live in real-time through high school
in 1992 in Irvine California where I
grew up which is a terrible suburb in
Southern California and so she is just
aching to be done with living there and
to get out and she starts meeting this
person who is Tess and Tess is telling
her things about how she should avoid
doing certain things and how she needs
to change her life and so the one thing
that these two characters have in common
aside from the fact that they keep
having these weird meetings in 1992 is
that they're both absolutely in love
with a punk rock band called Grape Ape
and this is something that they they
have in common with each other so I'll
talk about Grape Ape in a second we'll
definitely get there and I'll show you
some Grape Ape videos but I wanted to
start by talking about science so when I
first set out to do this novel because I
am a science journalist and because my
previous novel autonomous was considered
to be hard science fiction which is just
kind of a fake term for a science
fiction that sounds science II to us it
sounds like it could be plausibly true I
was like okay this is what I'm gonna do
I am gonna write the most hard science
fiction time-travel novel that's ever
been written it's gonna be so awesome
I'm gonna blow everyone away with my
scientific acumen so I called my friend
Sean Carroll who has just written a
great book about the origin of time and
space which is called something deeply
hidden and he teaches down at Caltech
and I'm like if anybody knows time how a
time machine would work it's gonna be
Sean so I get on the phone Sean I'm like
fired up and I'm like okay how am I
gonna do it and he's like no actually
like he kind of he was nice he didn't
actually completely laugh at me but he
said look I mean there's no such thing
as time travel it's never gonna happen
it's just not a thing it's not a thing
in physics it's not a thing in science
and so we started talking a little bit
more about how I could do it because at
that point I was kind of all in on the
whole time-travel thing I wasn't gonna
just yank that out of my story and be
like okay I have to stick to something
scientific
what can physics give me so he did in
fact give me wormholes he said fine use
wormholes that's vaguely plausible but
what he what are you and so there are
wormholes and I'll read you a little
section about that but what he really
did that was helpful and helpful in the
world building for me was he was like
look you can have something that is
fantasy like time travel but have
scientists respond to it the way a
scientist would and he said you know
look you you can have realistic science
that's built around something that seems
wildly implausible and that we don't
understand and that was really a great
way for me to kind of start out thinking
about this because there are really in
our world now there's kind of two types
of science
there's discovery science which is what
this time machine is part of and what
physics are part of and then there's
sort of in an innovation science which
is like technology it's like the class
that is the classic realm of the
time-travel stories innovation science
right a dude goes down into his basement
and builds a time machine right that's
the classic tale well I wanted to write
a story about discovery science about
scientists exploring something that they
didn't understand that didn't make sense
and so that's what brings me to Flin
Flon Manitoba this is the time machine
right here and it's because in my
universe I wanted the time machines to
fit into the way discovery sciences have
evolved and so my model was astronomy so
if you think about the history of
astronomy which eventually become
Astrophysics and that's why Sean Carroll
has a job it starts out as people just
sort of looking at the sky and recording
where the celestial bodies are they
don't know what those bodies are but
they they start to realize that they you
know have predictable patterns you can
follow them to get directions and then
over time it evolved into a kind of
mystical you know system and eventually
you know somewhere in the West somewhere
around the 18th century people start
saying wait a minute this could be
science and they start using scientific
instruments more more commonly to
examine these heavenly bodies and
eventually we get astronomy but
astronomy starts out as just a bunch of
people staring at stars and so I said
alright I love geology here's the thing
that humans have been doing for a really
long time
they've been pounding rocks together
it's very plausible that if you had a
time machine that was a naturally
occurring device in a rock at some point
some human is gonna pound on that rock
and activate the machine so that's how
my machines work is that you go to a
shield rock formation like this in
Manitoba this is on the Canadian Shield
this is good bedrock shield rock and if
you pound on it in the right way you
open up a wormhole and the wormholes as
far as we know only go to the past there
are some hints in the book that maybe
some people have figured out that they
can go both ways but they can only go to
the past as far as we know and I and so
humans have been playing around with
these machines since well we don't know
how long since the Paleolithic since
we're playing around with lithics right
and so there's early very early writings
from classical antiquity centered around
the city of Petra because you got to
have Petra in here because it's an
amazing city made out of ancient shield
rock formation and and of course it's in
I think it's in an Indiana Jones movie I
don't know anyway so there's a an
ancient city there and people discover a
time machine and so they start writing
about it
thousands and thousands of years ago and
it's only in you know the last couple
hundred years that people like test my
character have started to treat
time-travel as a science instead of just
like opening a magical portal into
somewhere so one of the things that I
really wanted to get at was like I said
that this that these time machines would
fit into a kind of a realistic way of
thinking about how scientists would
approach something that kind of made no
sense and that we didn't understand this
kind of discovery science and I also
wanted with that to kind of capture what
it is about science that fills us with
awe because when we talk about things
being on spiring in science looking up
into the sky and wondering about it or
looking into the cells of our bodies and
wondering how the Frick that chromosomes
actually work you know those are moments
of awe and wonder because we don't
understand how they work yet we will
figure it out I hope and so I'm gonna
read you just a short little bit where
Tess is going into the time machine
that's at Flin Flon fourth one is the
real is a name of a real place by the
way it's a mining town it's named after
a character in a science fiction novel
so Tess is at Flin Flon and and this is
what happens
I stood inside a vast hangar ceiling so
high that it sometimes generated its own
puffs of cloud and misty rain
the floor was pure Canadian Shield
bedrock a piebald of red and gray veined
with white covered in a few patches of
hardscrabble lichen here the Earth's
crust had endured virtually unchanged
for over three billion years studded
with metal deposits and ambiguous
Cambrian fossils the five known machines
had all been found in places like this
their control interfaces embedded in
rock that originated before life evolved
on land facing me was a row of
refrigerator-sized
server racks connected by fat wires too
bulky CRT monitors on desks she's in
1992 by the way she's traveling back to
her home time in 2022 so there's very
ancient technology embedded in the rock
and then semi ancient
surrounding her fat wires connected to
bulky CRT monitors on desks cameras on
metal stocks and something that looked
like the severed head of a traffic light
whose color signals had been replaced
with atmospheric sensors a couple of
texts typed on rugged keyboards booting
up the six tappers arranged in a circle
around me half a billion years ago these
machines had a sophisticated command
interface made from what geoscientists
called the ring and the canopy but now
all that was left was the rocky floor
the tappers invented in the 19th century
and refined in decades scents were crude
limited versions of what those old
interfaces must have been they looked
like low steel tables punctuated by
dozens of Pistons now moving up and down
in a test pattern essentially the tapper
was a reconfigurable set of padded
hammers like those inside a piano they
bang out a pattern on the rock that
pattern programmed the interface and the
interface would open a stable wormhole
between the present and the travelers
chosen destination in the past with
these humble devices we manipulated the
fabric of the cosmos geoscientists
barely understood the machines better
than the first humans to describe them
in writing thousands of years ago sure
we could control the exit date more
precisely than our Bronze Age ancestors
our tappers could produce complex
rhythms that were accurate to the
microsecond so that was progress we knew
each machine consisted of an interface
within the rock though so far our
instruments could not detect anything in
the rock other than the expected
elements then there was a wormhole that
came from somewhere sadly our biggest
breakthrough was probably that we
understood the machines behavior in the
context of geology rather than magic
even after thousands of years of using
them we still didn't know much about how
they worked let alone why so
she's about to enter the wormhole she's
not sure how this machine works but
she's still using it and again this is
the hallmark of discovery science it's
very ambiguous you know these are
characters who are playing around with
machines and with technologies that they
kind of know what to do with and it's
sort of the same like I said as
cosmology is now or a lot of Medicine is
now where we're kind of poking around
and we're like okay it seems to work
we're not sure why so once I owned in on
that idea of discovery science and the
kind of awe and ambiguity in it I did go
out to get a second opinion on whether
time machines could work because I was
just wanted to check just be sure so I
talked to a physicist named Adam Becker
and he told me something that I thought
was super great and was very formative
and creating this novel and he said look
time machines are not scientific devices
they're literary devices which is to say
I had to go outside the realm of science
to think about them I had to kind of go
into the realm of culture and history to
kind of think about how I would fuel the
action in this book and this is why the
ambiguity of discovery science is so
important because culture and history
and literary devices those are the realm
of ambiguity those are areas those are
types of systems that we use to talk
about things that are ambiguous you know
how history unfolds how society works
it's a pretty you can't just do
repeatable tests on it and get the same
result over and over again it's a little
frustrating but luckily I have a degree
in this I actually got my PhD in an
interdisciplinary field that kind of
straddled the line between social
science and the humanities so I have
been exposed to an extremely large
amount of literary theory so I felt that
I was up to the task and so what I did
was I changed my focus away from looking
just at the kind of the physics and the
science
there's plenty of that there's lots of
wormhole action and thought about how is
it that people intervene in history what
is it that thinkers have told us over
time about if you wanted to go back in
time you have your time machine we've
got them all over well we have five of
them but we have one up in Canada what
would you do to go back and change
things so of course over time my
geologists have been doing this and
they've accumulated a lot of data and it
turns out there's only certain things
you can do and there's a big debate
between two groups of travelers who are
basically kind of reiterating some of
the debates we have in a very boil down
form in the in the in history about how
historical change happens how do you
actually make a change so there's some
who believe in the great man theory
which is that you can target certain key
individuals like John Connor for example
or Hitler and if you take them out
you'll change history right just kill
that white guy and suddenly everybody's
free but then there's another school of
thought that tests my character belongs
to who believed in collective action and
they think the only way that history can
really change the only way you can make
a difference is if you actually form a
community or you join a community of
people and that that community builds up
over time and that the mass of people
are what changes history and so they've
kind of come to the conclusion after
years of research that you can't kill
Hitler and change history because you
just get like bit ler or zit ler Mittler
because Hitler isn't a special guy he's
just the face of a movement he's part of
a movement of white supremacy that swept
through Europe just the way now we have
a lot of politicians who are kind of you
know part of a new movement of white
supremacy that's sweeping across the
Europe and and the United States and so
my character TAS has to figure out a way
to change history by somehow engaging in
collective action and finding a way to
that and I was really influenced by LA
Kaufman's book direct action which came
out a few years ago
she's been heavily involved in activist
movements and she wrote this great
little short book super highly
recommended that's just about how two
movements work and how do you change
things by having a protest and why does
a protest work she really starts from
some basic fundamental questions about
like you know that level so from there I
got to my central metaphor in the book
which is that history is not a history
is not something that we can intervene
in scientifically we have to engage in
what's basically an edit war and so the
characters in the book are fighting and
edit war over the timeline and they
actually refer to it in those terms
again it's sort of a literary metaphor
it's taken from Wikipedia
and when they go back in time and they
change things they call it making an
edit and of course they're fighting
against a group who's reverting their
edits and so they're editing and
reverting and then there's sometimes
emerging conflicts and so you will if
you read the book you will find out what
the merging conflicts do to you it's not
pretty but they happen and so it allowed
me to sort of think about how how
history gets changed to come up with a
metaphor that wasn't just a scientific
way of looking at it but a kind of you
know a more ambiguous way of looking at
it you know in edit war is is something
that you know where the terms are
constantly shifting people are
constantly revising and I think it's a
great metaphor for basically how we
experience history and how we experience
memory so in order to build up this book
into the full kind of scope beyond just
these kind of fundamentals I had to sort
of tee up a problem in history and so as
I sort of mentioned before there's a
group of activists who are traveling
through time who are deleting women's
reproductive rights from history they're
editing history and Tess and her friends
are trying to revert those edits or
maybe make new edits they're not really
sure
how they're gonna do it but at the same
time I had to think about how would I
kind of center this around like a
personal problem for my characters and
so I'm not going to read you this
section because I want to kind of talk
to you more about the fun history but I
will just sum up for you that the sort
of central problem that the characters
are dealing with is that they're living
in a present day which for them is 2022
where women no longer have the right to
get an abortion in the United States but
at the same time the character Beth is
living in her own personal kind of
repercussions of that and because she
and her friends you know sometimes this
happens when you're living in Irvine and
you're punk rock girl sometimes you just
start murdering guys especially well
exclusively men who are rapists and
molesters of teenage girls so Beth of
her friends especially her friend Lizzie
start murdering guys and they're doing
it kind of in the name of like riot girl
feminism they're really interested in in
being you know feminist activists in
their own way meanwhile Beth is trying
to meanwhile Tess is of course trying to
change the past by not murdering anyone
but so the problem that I have sort of
teed up for this story was first of all
how do you change history but also how
do you deal with the repercussions of
living in a dark time line you know
because suddenly we have this problem
where teenage girls are taking justice
into their own hands and murdering
people and I don't need to tell you that
like murder is wrong right we all know
that murder is wrong so there's a bit of
a moral problem there so when tests our
time traveler goes back in time she's
thinking about two problems first
there's the problem of like how do I get
these dudes to stop deleting you know
reproductive rights from the timeline
but also how do I prevent women from
wanting to murder people to get revenge
for all the terrible things that are
happening to them because those are Bo
problems you know it's actually like I
said it turns out it's actually not cool
to murder guys even if they're rapists
and bad dudes you really should do like
what spider-man does right bring him to
prison turn them into the police right
it's what Batman does too
it's like standard you know logic so
anyway I have this problem and so you
always end up having to go back further
in history than you think to solve a
problem so I went back to the 19th
century to think about how you might get
an alternate history where American
women didn't have access to abortion and
it all turned out to have a lot to do
with Anthony Comstock now Anthony
Comstock was a real guy I'm about to
tell you real history this is not
alternate history this all actually
happened unbelievably so Anthony
Comstock was a moralist who was very
very famous in the 19th century for
going after people who were sending
obscene material through the mail
he was basically kind of a
self-appointed arbiter of moral ideas
and he managed to get a lot of rich
dudes in New York to support his cause
and he started his career at the YMCA
which used to be an activist
organization litigating on behalf of
Christian moralists so what Comstock was
most concerned about was pornography and
sex toys because this is in the kind of
the late 19th century when rubber starts
to be mass-produced so dildos especially
mail-order dildos were very very popular
so Comstock in order to prove that we
have this terrible problem with
obscenity going through the mail starts
ordering a lot of pornography and dildos
to come to him at the YMCA
so he gets about a steamer trunk full
and you know just just for research
purposes goes to Washington DC and
lobbies Congress to make new laws
governing sending obscene materials
through the mail he's saying you know
this
endangering children this is really
terrible and by the way he says there's
another kind of obscenity that we need
to regulate because there's all of these
women who are sending information
through the mail about birth control and
abortion and reproductive health and
that is also obscene because they're
talking about sex but these were of
course women who were feminists and who
were writing news letters to each other
about reproductive health and how to
prevent pregnancies and how to get rid
of unwanted pregnancies but he just
lumped them all in with these other
kinds of material that were much more
kind of well known as obscene materials
so Congress several members of Congress
come and look in the steamer trunk and
hang out with Anthony for a little while
and they check out the dildos and they
check out the porn and they're like yes
indeed this is all very bad and within a
few days legislation is introduced and
passed these become known as the
Comstock laws and the Comstock laws
forbids sending obscene material through
the mail including any information about
birth control sex toys or abortion so he
specifically wrapped up feminists in his
target group that he's going after so
the result of this is that a lot of
feminists in the era who are writing
newsletters about birth control start
getting arrested for obscenity and
they're given incredibly long prison
terms and several of them commit suicide
instead of going to prison as a protest
which Comstock starts bragging about in
his speeches and saying you know six
more women committed suicide you know
more more power to us at this point the
YMCA has cut him loose he's just working
on his own but he is being funded by a
lot of wealthy people so he's still
quite powerful and he continues to kind
of set the tone for what anti-feminist
rhetoric is going to be so his career in
our world in our timeline takes a turn
for the worse when he goes to the
World's Fair in
1893 the Columbian Exposition it was the
first World's Fair was held in Chicago
and it was also the first time that
people in the United States had seen
something that was called the dolls do
vault belly dancing we have a belly
dancer up there in the middle she was a
performer at the Algerian theatre that
was one of the more popular attractions
at the World's Fair so I'll tell you a
tiny bit about the World's Fair and then
I'll tell you what Anthony did so at the
World's Fair there's the white City
which you guys have probably all heard
about you've probably heard about this
book the devil in the white city where
there's some the whole book is all about
how there's like a dude killing women
there's only women killing men in my
book so we don't have that guy in my
book and the white City was you know the
very beautiful part of the World's Fair
that was devoted to educating people
about science and teaching them about
new technologies including like the
Dynamo which was going to transform the
world with electricity but there was
another part of the World's Fair the
part that actually made money and that
people actually went to which was called
the Midway and the Midway was a long
park that kind of stuck out like a sort
of like a tongue from the moon from the
White City and it was full of
attractions like the Algerian theatre
like here you can see it's a one of the
other attractions was called the streets
of Cairo and it was a big reproduction
of like of various like the Luxor Temple
and flints from from ancient Egypt and
it was kind of like Disneyland and in
fact one of Disney's relatives actually
worked there so he Walt Disney may have
kind of heard some tips about how to do
stuff like this and they had a lot of
Acts with belly dancers in them because
a lot of these theaters were trying to
bring sort of North African culture to
the US and they were actually performers
who were from North Africa belly dancing
is a kind of it's like a fusion of a
bunch of different kind of native dances
from various parts of North
it's not a real kind of ethnic dance
it's just a sort of fusion but to
Americans at the time it was pretty darn
racy Mark Twain wrote about how he
almost had a heart attack watching them
and so Comstock was like I am gonna shut
this [ __ ] down so he goes from New York
to Chicago gets a court order to shut
down the Midway he's targeting
especially one place called the Persian
palace where they had these dolls Duve
entre ladies but he's trying to shut
down every single attraction and so he
gets the court order and like I said
this is this is making tons of money for
the city of Chicago no Chicago judge is
gonna let this happen because they're
making so much cash so there's an
immediate injunction he's unable to do
it
he totally loses and he looks like a
fool and so then the newspapers start
making fun of him so that's what happens
in our timeline that's kind of the
beginning of the end of Anthony
Comstock's hold on America's imagination
except for the fact that Comstock laws
stayed on the books until like the 1970s
in a lot of places but in my novel I
created an alternate timeline and here's
what I did just to be mean and sneaky so
I wanted to think about an alternate
history where women's history was
centered instead of your standard kind
of like what was the outcome of World
War two what was the outcome of the
Civil War so instead of caring about the
outcome of the Civil War in terms of
like which group of white guys with guns
one I was interested in what happened
afterwards during the arguments over who
would get to vote so there was this big
question in the wake of the Civil War
over whether black people would get the
vote whether freed slaves would get the
vote whether you had to be literate to
get the vote and also would women get
the vote and there'd been a long-running
suffrage movement for women by that time
for decades in fact the first woman who
ran for president ran in 1872 that was
Victoria Woodhull she also was the first
female Wall Street broker she was great
she in our own newspaper called wood
holes quarterly
and so she ran for president
unsuccessfully at any rate in my
alternate history instead of freed
slaves getting the vote but women not
getting the vote until 1919 they all get
the vote at the same time so women start
voting in 1870 and one of the first
things that they do is they elect
Harriet Tubman the great civil war hero
as to the Senate so instead of having
susan b anthony as the great hero of the
women's movement its Harriet Tubman and
that really changes a lot of things and
I mean partly it changes feminism itself
it changes the way the nation
understands women's power and it results
in a backlash just the way history works
right so women get more rights earlier
but then there's a stronger backlash
against women and so Comstock manages to
shut down the Midway and as a result his
laws get stronger and hit the injunction
again in the sending information through
the mail about abortion remains illegal
women who advocate for abortion and
birth control are sent to prison and so
we never get reproductive rights in the
United States women get to vote earlier
and better but we don't get to have
abortions or any kind of reproductive
health care so I wanted to have a
history that felt kind of rich and
complicated you know ambiguous so that
it wasn't just like and then we got the
vote and everything was awesome one of
the other things that happens as a
result of this transformation in history
is that feminist culture changes this is
another thing that I think is funny that
it never gets treated in alternate
histories like we endlessly I don't want
to just keep picking on Civil War novels
but we endlessly kind of go back to the
Civil War and say like well what would
happen if this happened what would
happen if this person won or this person
wasn't a general but we never ask
questions like what would happen if
feminism was totally different
so what if what if feminism were started
by a woman of color who had been a slave
like how would that change the way
feminism works and so one of the really
weird outcomes of this or unexpected
outcomes of this is that the riot girl
seen in the 1990s winds up being really
different so if you recall from your
history of punk rock in the 1990s the
riot girls scene was you know women who
were entering the punk scene they were
playing loud music and there were a lot
of women of color involved in local
scenes in LA and here where I lived but
the bands that became popular were
almost all fronted by white women and
that was just because we live in a
culture where feminism the history of
feminism is kind of associated with
white women it hasn't really had it
hadn't especially in the 1990s really
met the idea of intersectionality which
now seems so obvious to all of us so as
a result of Harriet Tubman being elected
in 1992 the band Grape Ape that both
Beth and test love is a band of Latinas
from LA who get to be super big and
super influential and they're women of
color and they sing about racial issues
they sing about immigration and
injustice and so even though we've
gotten this more conservative culture
where women don't have reproductive
rights we have a way more awesome and
progressive and badass punk rock scene
so thanks you to Harriet Tubman Thank
You senator Harriet Tubman so I wanted
to end by with just a couple of final
thoughts before we open it up for
conversation which is that part of what
I was trying to do with this book was
kind of question this notion that we
ought this phrase that we've all heard
which is that you know if we forget
history we're doomed to repeat it I
don't actually think that is
the issue I think the issue is that we
don't imagine revisiting history and
revising it that we don't go back and
rethink our history and I think part of
the reason why it's great to have a book
about time travel that's set in an
alternate timeline is that it reminds us
that we're always changing the past it
gives me and gives you as readers a way
of thinking about what does it mean to
be changing history because now
historians actual real historians not
fake ones in my book really buy into
this idea that all of history is kind of
revisionist history especially when
we're constantly excavating new stories
from history because history isn't
written by winners exclusively history
is written by everybody and the more
expansive our view of history is the
more voices we have the more people that
we have telling that history the more
history changes and so it's not really
about not repeating history it's about
looking at history from another
perspective like from the perspective of
belly dancers or from the perspective of
feminists or somebody who ran for
president in 1890 1873 even though she
couldn't vote and there's a really
strong
I think conservative idea that we
shouldn't touch history I think the
whole phrase make America great again is
kind of about that it's about saying
look there was a history that America
had an untouched unrevised history we
need to go back to that and a time
travel story at its best
always says you know make history
expansive no don't make it something
that it already was don't keep going
back to that same history you know go
back to new histories learn about new
perspectives and so my next book I'm
going to give you a quick sneak peek is
a nonfiction book about archaeology
where I'm gonna be looking at alternate
histories or alternative voices in
history real histories but alternative
voices in history
this is a cover that you're not supposed
to be seeing so but this is the cover of
my next book and there will be something
that isn't just a Greek quote at the
bottom which I love I went to a bunch of
different cities and and looked at them
from the perspective of ordinary people
who lived there so I actually talked to
an archaeologist who said to me you know
[ __ ] Julius Caesar like we don't care
about him anymore we want to know about
the people who ran the bars we want to
know about the people who were
prostitutes we want to know about the
people who were slaves and so that was
what I looked for in the four cities
that I talked about in the book and I
even did some excavating there where I
was like worrying about 40 layers of
sunscreen and I look really great so so
in the end I think maybe we should just
start talking and I don't need to play
the video I don't know do you guys want
to see a little bit of Grape Ape alright
so in order to make this alternate
history come to life
I got some friends of mine who were very
talented musicians and videographers to
write and perform a Grape Ape song so
this the lyrics to this song appear in
the book in a slightly different form
than they appear in this song because
that's how it is right like sometimes
you sing the song differently right and
so here's a little taste of grape we're
just gonna play a little bit from the
beginning of the video wait
no we made them up no they are not but I
wish they were they were you know
they're from an alternate history where
women of color I mean women of color in
my alternate history led some of the
most popular right girl bands in the 90s
so um this is a band that yeah like I
made it up my friend desi Lopez he's an
amazing performer wrote the music and
yeah here you go
wait did it work okay
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
annalee I want to I want to call out
great babe y'all so is is there
SoundCloud for great babe can we wear is
like it's on YouTube search for creepy
when's the vinyl come out man we're time
travel already back to vinyl come on
there's a bunch of awesome people in
this video who are cool feminists from
the Bay Area that you might recognize
and let's talk yeah and a shout out to
Arielle Waldman who's who is one of the
very first speakers here at the interval
yeah yeah no she's there where I'm in
NASA as [ __ ] t-shirt for alternate
history right girls thank you that's a
big round of applause
so much to talk about we're gonna have
microphone going around saying well
we'll talk for a little bit first let's
see a 1-1 quick just to sort of check in
on Auto because we talked about this and
but this is sort of your vision you
wanna this is my yeah my vision so this
is I just Auto art our chalkboard
drawing machine if you're not familiar
here you can see in the middle of
wormhole and on the right hand side is
the TARDIS does everybody know what the
TARDIS is that's a time machine it
actually it the doctor from Doctor Who
rides around and it goes through time
and space which makes things much more
interesting and then on this side we
just see rocks and water which of course
is what my team time machine is made of
and and so the the device the the actual
mechanism for time travel if I get this
right they go in and they kind of bang
on the rocks
yeah and it's something about the rhythm
that they're doing it's something about
the rhythm and which of course goes into
kind of music again and how this is kind
of a book about so what I'm taking away
is that math rock is time travel is that
okay good
anything with a beat you know like and
the more complex to be rare so like
techno is probably like great so if they
shift into six forget about it it's just
we'll find out and and are you and and
we're talking we talked a little bit
about because you you've done kind of a
deeper dive into the history of you know
the different types of what are sort of
the flavours of time travel
sci-fi because this your alternative
timeline styles time travel right and
there and they're there other ones in
like there is like a ton of different
kinds um
there's of course the standard type
where it's a guy in his basement
a guy in a basement yeah making a
DeLorean or something like that and then
there's of course well there's the two
primary branches of time-travel there's
the single universe and the multiverse
types I chose a single universe which is
kind of in the style of Terminator or
back to the future where if you go
into the past and change something it
affects the future that you are
returning to and I wanted to do that
because I wanted there to be
consequences for my characters but in
the multi-verse version you go back in
time and you change something and you
branch a new universe right so you might
have like a zillion universes kind of
like in like the Transformers universe
or something like that or like maybe the
Marvel Universe but there's like a
million alternate timelines and then I
think there's like I said I mean within
that if you have the kind of single
universe as I kind of hinted at there
are stories where changing the past is
really really bad sort of the butterfly
effect idea that if you just step on a
butterfly in the Cretaceous period if
you come back to the present day some
kind of fascist will have become
president
that's literally what happens in the
original Ray Bradbury story where the
butterfly effect idea comes out of it's
called the sound of thunder and then
there's the idea that like in my book
we're changing the past is actually
really hard and so kind of defeating
Anthony Comstock for my characters
becomes incredibly difficult takes years
and it's it's not at all obvious how to
change history you can't just step on a
butterfly as I said you can't shoot
Hitler or John Connor so so I just like
to take this quick moment to introduce a
radical conspiracy theory okay so so you
are I you you well we have actually
let's do a big shout out to borderlands
books great in the local fantastic
bookstore
who have a bunch of your books and we
have your nonfiction work here as well a
conspiracy theory don't I didn't forget
about it so so this is this is one your
non-fiction books do you want to say
sure this is an on this is my first
major non-fiction book called scatter
adapt and remember it's about mass
extinction and the evidence that humans
will survive the next mass extinction it
might not be a great survival but what
that survival would look like and how we
could kind of make it a little bit
better than living in caves eating bugs
and then we also have autonomous which
was your your last and award-winning
novel and and so all these books back
there and they're all they'll sign and
you'll be sticking around and and
personalizing them as well but the
radical conspiracy theory which you've
all been waiting for is that since
you're writing both nonfiction and
science fiction it is completely
possible and consistent that these
science fiction novels might actually be
histories and that in fact we are living
inside and so Grape Ape may be a band
that actually will exist in about three
months time or something once that edit
gets made is is that is that possible is
is is this reality as we've experienced
it consistent with the premise the world
that you've built in your book no well
you'd have to okay in order for Grape
Ape to exist you would have to have gone
back and changed the 19th century right
because remember we have to change the
whole history of feminism in order to
get a riot girl movement where women of
color are bleeding the most popular band
so you could do it if you went back you
know over a hundred years and you know
organized with feminists in the late
19th century so that could happen okay
and if it did happen we would have had a
better right girl scene uh-huh
one of the other things that changes in
my in my timeline by the way is that Tim
Burton made Wonder Woman movies in the
90s instead of Batman movies which would
mean that by now we'd be on like the
third iteration of the Wonder Woman
movies and we'd finally have like a
black Wonder Woman and things would be
so awesome
so is there a is there a 60s version of
Wonder Woman ala Batman that's like the
Adam West Batman I would like to see
that seems we'd like to see yeah okay
maybe yeah and and so is there a sequel
plan and can it be that that's the next
question and and I'm curious about
because so with something like this
you're obviously we talked about
world-building a little bit last time
you were here
I mean you're building more world than
actually gets showcased in this book so
I'm always kind of curious with
something like this what's on the
cutting room floor and and in particular
maybe on Harriet Tubman did you go deep
into
like what her policies were what what
she what what what things were affected
that led to this or what are some of
your favorite things that are outside
what we actually will learn in the novel
that that that you built into the world
anything you can I mean definitely there
is some stuff about Harriet Tubman which
doesn't come up that much she we don't
ever we actually meet Comstock briefly
we don't ever meet Harriet Tubman
although one of the characters does go
back to the 19th century and campaign
for her so we kind of meet the people
who were on the campaign trail and like
we learn about some of her policies but
we also don't learn about the other time
machines very much the characters do go
visit the first time machine ever
discovered at Petra which winds up being
really interesting because there's lots
of features of that time machine where
people can kind of stash written
documents nearby and they will endure
even when the timeline changes so it's
the only place where we have records of
timelines that have been deleted
although of course you never know if
they're true or not because people might
make [ __ ] up and then be like oh yeah
that was deleted but we used to have
really great animal rights but no we
don't so they don't ever know for sure
if those records but so anyway so we
don't know a lot about the other
machines there's one in Australia
there's one at Timbuktu we don't learn
about that and there is one chapter
that's on the cutting room floor that I
might turn into a short story where the
group of feminists that Tess works with
who are called the daughters of Harriet
are all going back on their own missions
so there's a couple chapters in the book
where we get like their side missions
and there's one side mission that I cut
where a woman goes back to Stanford in
the 1950s to an AI lab that's being run
by this monstrous misogynist guy who is
harassing one of the women in his lab
and because he's harassing her so much
she's going to leave the lab and leave
AI and basically destroy the future of
computing and so she has to kind of go
back and make sure that this doesn't
happen and that this woman manages to
stay in the field and it may or may not
be based on an actual Stanford professor
I don't know
composite character I'm totally going to
Petra and looking for Grape Ape demos
that may have been stashed yes totally
seems plausible to me still taking this
and we're gonna have a mic going around
here and and we're gonna have we have
prizes for people that ask questions is
that right we do if you win you will get
a patch that says we're in the wrong
time line you can sew it onto your skin
or your clothing or onto your stuffed
animals or people that you don't like
I'm gonna get and before we get to
audience question I mean I want to dive
in one more with you because we've known
each other a long time it's great like
running around in the night and it's so
exciting to see everything that you're
doing you've had this really interesting
career you are writing nonfiction you're
writing science journalism with hours
Technica etcetera and but also you are
experiencing this change in media as all
this you know golden age of television
whatever all the rise of the blog's the
you know the the death of the blog's all
these things yes I'd love for you to
talk a little bit about all right
anybody out there
fans of io9.com the well then a lot of
you are gonna be tomorrow because so so
you and Charlie James right can you tell
us the story cuz I don't think I know
the story of how I own I and actually
started and and I guess first you do a
better job of saying what what was the
mission state of iodine and how it all
began
um so it started when I was working at
Wired and you know the print magazine so
that was how ancient this was and I had
before that I had been working at the
San Francisco Bay Guardian so it's kind
of a print II person but I had
definitely done some online work and so
the managing editor of Gawker Media
contacted me and I thought you know he
said I want to talk to you about doing
some work
this is Lockhart Steele who wound up
founding curbed later so if you read
curbed
you can tell Lockhart I sent you so he
said yeah I come talk to me and I
thought he was gonna make kind of
overtures to me about writing for
Valleywag which I really didn't like
and I was kind of I was a little dubious
so I got stoned before I went to the
meeting and because there's whatever and
Valleywag the gossip magazine valley
dark chapter Indiana it was a dark
chapter in in Gawker media's history
yeah so so I was not fully prepared when
they when he said to me I you stoned
yeah it's not fully prepared to to
expect that he would say oh actually we
were trying to start a science fiction
blog and we'd love for you guys to work
on our for you to work on it not you
guys because it was just me at that time
and I was really excited about that idea
and I immediately said well what about
combining because I was a science
journalist I am a science journalist I
said what about combining science
reporting like really good science
reporting with news about science
fiction and reviews and bring in people
who were interested in the science part
but might be kind of fiction curious and
people who were really into the fiction
but like would really love to learn more
about the actual science and so that
became after many many months of
arguments and debates that became our
editorial mandate and my first hire was
Charlie Jane Anders who is now an
incredibly accomplished science fiction
writer and critic and we spent like six
months just doing this thing that they
used to call it Gawker media blogging in
the dark which just meant that we were
literally blogging for the audience of
our boss Nick Denton who would just
periodically come by and just basically
scream at us but by text so is like text
yelling this is bad so we were just bad
for a really long time and then when we
launched we had like six months of
content and people were like holy [ __ ]
you know where's where did this come
from and and we were the last blog that
was launched by Gawker Media so we kind
of we were the we're the final nail in
the wall that sounds bad we were the we
were the final property in that family
of blogs and io9 is still going for the
last little balloon that went up yeah we
were the last balloon pretty big balloon
though we it was a very popular site
from the beginning and it's now part of
Gizmodo
and it was really I think the thing
about it that was really the winning
formula was that combination of having
really good science reporting with
really fun entertainment reporting and
it was funny because science journalists
and scientists would always say to me
like oh you know the sugar coating of
like having all that pop culture is
what's bringing people in but actually
behind the scenes under the covers all
of the articles that were the most
popular that got the most views were all
science articles those were the ones
that really blew up the biggest that
would get like millions of views so
who's to say what the sugar pill was you
know like maybe it was the science
bringing people in to learn more about
time travel you know so it's hard to say
alright and we have we have a mic up
there do we have an audience okay so our
first patch our I know would you like to
be the patch deliverer yeah I mean I do
I do all the beds please thank you for
asking question how's it going um I love
your t-shirt and your talk was amazing
and representing for leti great yeah um
okay so when you put the timeline up and
2022 abortion is illegal that was very
striking and frightening to me did you
do that to me on purpose like did you
did you do this yeah I'm like what's
this how did you not or how did you
decide to make it so soon and not maybe
like you know even ten years in the
future or well because in so in the in
the novel the history has been changed
for a long time so because of the fact
that women got the vote earlier there's
been this late 19th century backlash so
really the fact that abortion has
remained illegal until 2022 is quite odd
it's almost like there's time travelers
who were meddling with things and I will
say and this is not a spoiler that you
know my approach to this novel changed
while I was writing it I was writing it
I just started writing it when Trump was
elected and after the election and after
watching
how much changed so fast I no longer
really felt like it was realistic to
have a book where I had sort of started
out thinking my characters wouldn't
change anything and everything would
stay kind of crappy and I was like no
because I'm watching the history change
before my eyes so they do succeed in
changing the timeline the feminists do
have a a kind of victory I mean of
course there's always more to do and
there's there's always going to be those
guys who are messing around with the
timeline working against them but it is
a hopeful book and so they are in a
world where abortion is illegal but they
are able to change that and you know
other things are lost of course but you
know they do they do win kind of and I'm
gonna get in a question from our online
viewers thanks to folks that are
watching here's your online patch well
post a gift so the question is with no
name attached to it but after
researching writing this book and as the
science journalist you are as well as a
sci-fi writer living here in space-time
how do you think it really works are
there infinite parallel timelines is
time travel possible we're not going to
put you on the spot or anything is
reality literally a story or narrative
from some higher form of consciousness I
think history is a story from human
consciousness so that's for sure
unfortunately time travel does not exist
I've been told now by two fairly
prominent physicists that it's not
possible and you know I have been a lot
of things but science is kind of the
main thing I have faith in so I think
it's probably true that we will never
have literal time-travel but of course
we travel in our imaginations all the
time and part of the reason why I think
were drawn to time-travel narratives is
because of the fact that the process of
learning about history is always a
process of revising history because the
more we understand it the more we learn
the more history changes and that
changes our understanding of who
we are and so I think if there's any
kind of intelligence at work
it's our intelligence as humans trying
to figure out how we got here who we are
how our problems started and I think one
of the things I learned in researching
this book is that you always have to go
back a lot further than you think in
order to figure out the root of a lot of
the problems that we're dealing with and
I mean sure you can go back to like the
dawn of humanity if you want but in the
modern age you know like I said when I
was thinking about reproductive rights I
was like wow it really does start kind
of far back like we think of you know
roe v wade and and you know the 1960s is
really this this turning point for
reproductive rights but it was really in
like the 1860s and the 1870s when a lot
of our ideas about about reproduction
and about women's rights and then men's
rights to control women's rights that's
where all that stuff comes from and a
lot of Comstock's rhetoric if you read
his writing it sounds a lot like what
we're hearing today from men's rights
activists they could really I mean maybe
they are reading Comstock I don't know
but it's again what his years are so
Comstock is most active in the starting
in like the late 1860's and then he
lives up until about 1916 and in fact he
got into a huge late in his life his
main focus was on trying to shut down
Planned Parenthood or the the
organization that became Planned
Parenthood run by Margaret Sanger and so
he and Margaret Sanger were at odds and
the year after he died the first Planned
Parenthood clinic opened so that was he
cleared the way sounds terrible but you
just reminded me something I don't know
if you've seen and and for folks that
are enjoying this talk another one of
our talks you might like and the videos
online was Carolyn Wintour who's at
Stanford did this talk about the the
history of the history of deep time the
concept of deep time which comes in the
19th century and and because of
geological discoveries and suddenly we
have new metaphors like the layering of
our consciousness this sort of like it
bets geological layers and and it's an
interesting thing because at the time
before television before cinema there
there it was actually painting it's the
Hudson River Valley painters who are
starting to show this these geological
you know configurations that in the
rocks and by focusing those in pain
those details that was the media by
which those ideas were disseminating and
an influence psychology and all these
other things too so there's a reason why
I brought geology into a book about time
travel because I really wanted to kind
of evoke that and my characters do end
up going back to the Ordovician period
about half a billion years ago so so if
you read the book you'll find out how to
eat trilobite so that's just like a
sales pitch is basically yeah alright
and we have another audience question
right here in please so first I have a
quick comment are you aware of
Napoleon's quote that what is history
but a fable agreed upon napoleon doesn't
even exist in this alternate but it just
shows about how history is yeah people
say history exactly and i mean i think
that's a kind of more accurate version
of history is written by the winners
because in fact it isn't always written
by the winners so yeah it's it's a it's
a story we tell ourselves so do you
subscribe you do not subscribe to the
great man theory of history for example
if hitler had been killed at the end of
world war one and he was actually in the
gun sights of a british soldier who is
known by name and who did not pull the
trigger only because his Hitler was a
messenger and he did not have a gun in
his hand at the time so the British
soldier thought it wouldn't be fair play
to actually shoot the guy that he yeah
and so so if Hitler hadn't lived or if
he had been killed in right you possibly
still would have had Germany go into a
very dark place in a very far right you
know nationalists even National
Socialist position but you probably
wouldn't have had World War two and all
the way it played out because World War
two is largely based least in Europe on
Hitler and
the decisions that he made most of which
were bad which ultimately resulted in
Germany actually losing the war well
that's what you think because you're
taking kind of a great man perspective
and not looking at all the people around
him who were advising him well no he was
he was actually he was actually he was
actually overruling his advisors so so
his generals are actually advising him
to do different it is in fact a whole
body of research not just about Hitler
yeah but about history itself sort of
looking into how do movements form how
does history change what causes people
to follow a particular leader for
example Hitler is nothing without his
followers of course so I mean he's just
gonna be a boring art student and so the
question that I was asking in this book
was really how do you kind of balance
out those two ideas how do you think
about the way movements and collectives
change history but there are these
inflection points right like Anthony
Comstock is the big bad in my book and
the characters have conversations about
this where they're like one character
who actually comes from very far in the
future really does believe in the great
man theory and she feels like all I have
to do is murder Anthony Comstock and
they're good and my character test is
like no first of all murder is wrong and
second of all that's not how it works
and so they kind of they wind up coming
to an ambiguous place and again that's
part of the the aw and wonder in history
and and in human behavior is that it's
ambiguous it's not just Hitler it's not
just the movement it's some kind of
combination it's ineffable we can't
tease it all out and so they kind of
have to do both they kind of have to
start a movement and they kind of have
to figure out a way to get at Anthony
Comstock the person and so I think
ultimately like I said it's it's a
little of both
and and again you can't have a great man
or a great woman or a great non-binary
person or whatever without all of the
people who make them that they are only
as
as their followers or their community so
the four cities and that's a great yeah
in my next book the four cities are
catalhoyuk which is a Neolithic city in
central Turkey it was about 9,000 years
ago and some people think it's one of
the first cities some people have to say
no it's not really a city it's ambiguous
Pompeii Angkor which is the site of the
famous temple at angkor wat and Cahokia
which is an indigenous city here in the
United States it's in southern Illinois
across the river from st. Louis it's a
beautiful mound city with big pyramids
it's now a UNESCO World Heritage Site so
if you're in st. Louis please do just
check it out give a little money to the
museum there and the premise of the book
is just that these were all cities that
were very central to their civilizations
and people abandoned them and why did
they abandon them you think you know why
they abandoned Pompeii okay but you
think you know but there's more to it
it's complicated but yes obviously
there's some some mitigating
circumstances and what's the timeline of
your four cities book coming out coming
out in July July so yeah it's done
that's it the next one 2020 okay 2020
that's right so yep and you also already
have your next book for tour I do yes I
do as soon as I on Monday when I turn in
the final edits for for lost cities they
were actually due yesterday but I got an
extension my editor was don't tell
anyone she's out tonight okay and I
worked very hard on it all day so let
that be on the record so so yeah so I've
signed a two book deal with tour so I
have two more novels that coming out
with them the next one is going to be a
multi-generational terraforming epic
which because I'm me is mostly going to
be about water treaties and public
transit but there will be
a sentient flying train has a character
so I promise you that
and then the book after that is gonna be
it's kind of inchoate but it's gonna be
a kaiju love story so it might not be
very scientific
so the Nick the book the terraformers
the terraforming book that will be very
hard science fiction kaiju love story
probably not quite as yeah you'll have
to find out
annalee new it's big round of applause
everyone thank you
[Music]